Gabby congratulations how does it feel
to be engaged thank you it feels great
yeah it feels like I'm on cloud nine is
there anything that you've learned about
Eric now that you're outside of the
bachelor world and with without the
cameras rolling oh so many things
um just like you know stuff that you
learn kind of spending a lot of time
together
um yeah but all no I mean good things
some bad any anything that annoys you
um like yeah he Hogs the bathroom sink
so annoying when I try and brush my
teeth he'll like push me out of the way
and I was like I'm here first uses my
face wash and my shampoo
so there's a lot
Rachel obviously was a very emotional
night for you but it ended with all
smiles when you walked off the stage
with even can you tell us what happened
when you walked off the stage yeah I was
obviously very shocked to see him and I
kind of just was wondering what he was
doing here and it was just really great
to see him and he told me he just wanted
to be there and support me in that
moment so it was
um a nice ending to something that was
really difficult
um is there any chance for
reconciliation are you guys back
together in any way I don't know
everyone's gonna have to wait and see I
think we're definitely just taking
things organically and we'll see if it
goes anywhere
so obviously this is the book the first
time we saw two bachelorettes
simultaneously finding love do you think
it worked and do you think that they
will do this format again
such a loaded question it is yeah it's
so hard because at the end of the day I
mean people saw my ending not go so well
but I always have Gabby next to me and I
truly could never imagine going through
this process without her but I mean it
was definitely tough and it provided a
lot of challenge so I think moving
forward they would have to be able to
navigate it as well as we did this time
yeah and it's really right I think it's
up to the individuals you know who are
in our position because Rachel and I
really did put our friendship first I
think we could have made so many
different decisions and not be in the
position that we're in right now but
overall I think we're both really
grateful to have always put our
friendship first because we ended up you
know together and supportive of each
other so yeah
obviously Gabby The Bachelor the last
couple past couples haven't really had
the best track record of staying
together why do you think you and Eric
have what it takes to go for forever
um we've had to work on our
communication so much so I think just
being long distance you know getting off
this crazy environment that you can't
really relate to real life until you get
there it really kind of pushes your
boundaries and makes you work together
if you do want to make it work and him
and I are pretty dedicated to each other
and even though our communication isn't
the best we have good intentions and we
hold each other accountable so I feel
like communication is key and it's
pretty good but we'll see
well couples have it
[Laughter]
um Rachel obviously Zach was announced
as the next Bachelor how do you feel
having your ex in that position oh my
gosh well obviously we're both so
excited for him we can't wait to watch
his journey it is difficult being a lead
you have to kind of learn on fly so we
wish him the best of luck and I think
we're excited to you know watch him and
see another Bachelor season that we're
not on this time
yeah it'll be fun to be a viewer again
right nice to have the pressure off
but Rachel we did see you in the promos
for Bachelor in Paradise so is that just
a cameo or are you actually looking for
love on the beach
I don't know they're gonna have to wait
and see
but no I will feel like
that would have been a quick turnaround
right yeah well that's why it was so
confusing I was like wait is she on it
like what's happening here yeah
um
Rachel I want to go back to that hard
meeting you had with Tino was there ever
a point that you thought you guys could
work it out or did you go into that
knowing that it was completely over
it's so hard I mean this is such I feel
like a loaded question when he told me
find if anyone's ever been in this
position just kind of goes numb and
blank and all you need is answers I need
to see him I need to get these answers
so that's immediately what I did and
from there I tried to figure out what I
needed and it just spiraled from there
ultimately but yeah I mean just going in
ultimately what I needed was to figure
out why and how it happened
and obviously I I'm sure you've seen
this but a bunch of the guys from your
season went out a couple nights ago and
there was
um a bottle brought out with a sign that
said in lack for better words aftino was
do you think they had animosity towards
him just living together or was this in
direct support of you I don't think the
boys knew um the person who bought the
sign um because I know there really is
no bad blood with the boys so I really
think it kind of was just somebody
circumstantial and there was Crossfire
that should have probably not been
posted of course we just wouldn't
condone that and I don't think of course
either right
um and with the both of you with is
there anything that you would change in
this journey any decision you regret
what would you go back in or or would
you change anything
I always say no you know I don't have
any regrets I think you have to listen
to yourself while going through this
journey and we're all just doing the
best we can and we make mistakes to
learn from them and I think you know
we're here where we're supposed to be
for a reason yeah so no matter how hard
it is
um I don't think I would have changed at
anything yeah and I mean I made so many
mistakes I'll be the first to admit I
was not perfect and being able to watch
that back and learn has been so valuable
to me and I'm gonna carry all these
lessons moving forward in my life so
regardless of outcome I would have not
changed it because now I can take
everything with me and kind of move
forward in in my life and I think
Gabby's going to do the same
and with all those lessons now that
you've got girls have learned what would
you what advice would you give to Zach
um
yeah or not at all I mean there's so
many different ways to do it it's really
your own Journey so it's it's specific
to the person we're all different people
I think ultimately what me and Gabby
always did was we followed our hearts to
a fall and and I think we definitely did
get some heat for that but yeah it's
your journey at the end of the day and
you just really have to be true to
yourself because at the end of the day
it's an engagement and it's it's a
really big deal so just kind of trusting
your gut I guess is the advice I would
give yeah
and Gabby obviously you killed it on
Dancing With the Stars and Rachel's your
biggest fan on there
what was that experience like that first
dance oh my gosh it was wild I was
having so many feelings so many thoughts
and nerves
um but just ultimately filled with
gratitude that I got to see Rachel you
know before I actually took the stage it
was such a grounding moment and having
all my friends and family there and and
you know Val's great as a partner so
it's just honestly it was one of the I
think biggest moments of my life the
best time so yeah
well amazing it was so great chatting
with you girls you killed it
um it was really great watching you guys
and I can't wait to see what you guys do
next
thank you